oops welcome to this video jbg and I'm
going g-iii okay yeah g3 we play the
kingside fianchetto the whole week ok
that's an interesting setup that is
going for him ha Quincy to whom taking
them that's a bit of an uncommon moment
to take all night III maybe so 95
yeah that's an interesting wave to play
with age 6 there are a couple of
versions of that that kind of thing not
sure how this is oh this is faring
compact with the others leads to very M
yeah very unconventional structures ok
he's here for him it's obviously the
most normal thing ever and he plays
immediately so let's see bb3 he can move
move as a king's Knight
what you better put that I can go be
three though I mean night g4s not not on
i think i can get that i can just take
that must be quite a good compensation i
think at that very tricky position okay
let's play that possibly night and sorry
Luke a three that is an idea of that
move using the look on the third-ranked
sote three it was my idea and let's get
this going okay so maybe a five
attending a six a very strange position
with this very very weird bishop on c1
maybe for Knight b6 hang a coffee am
sorry you need that coffee badly um so I
can't even go know I cannot root d3 is
going night before
okay so let's attack the g5 pawn so just
going to push that no he's giving giving
it away okay 43 I guess and now and
night night should be six maybe would
like to prevent him from castling but
I'm not sure that I can manage that
very very very strange so now
he's a ticking g5 that's possible there
are possible discoveries by the night
hmm I guess Jim that wasn't great
probably
going here looking at e seven
I don't really know what this position
what this is should be four is not
leading anywhere okay let's see here I
wanted to take it seven but ok let's do
it like that and possibly queen bee
seven some equal material but very hard
two very hard to figure out time works
not sure do I am I losing now rook e1 me
check check oh I didn't see that move at
all and he will see a rookie one yeah
and I was totally irritated check and
this in this game white resigned
completely completely bonkers position
so I went down Jim I really don't know
what that is it's just totally weird
material is equal 5 is 6 that I mean
that looks fairly normal down and here i
would really think that it should be
somehow okay for white what is the
engine giving rook be three okay I
really didn't think about Queen f5 which
was strong cook be three yeah it said
that just just a completely random
position that's not really that's not
exactly my my strong side we need to
cancel that is actually just good for
white the whole thing Bishop e7 is good
wow why I have this move I didn't see
that one okay yeah that mean okay I
didn't want to take their on c6 and then
only seven but if I would have seen that
rookie three as possible of course I
would have taken like that this is
actually quite nice now now that the
system
the engine evaluation okay so i did that
yet it already gets gets very tricky
yeah just I just overlooked prenat
stream yeah that those games sometimes
there's a couple of situation where you
really shouldn't play a game like right
after dinner it's what I just tried
you're kind of sitting there and if you
like oh yeah well no excuses or anything
it's just I feel that it's interesting
to to get them get an idea how you how
you fan shares in certain situations and
there are some nutritional things that
that you really should avoid I think
playing right after dinner it's probably
not the correct idea ok yeah whatever
whatever weird what a weird line they
are here of course I have also this move
but I wasn't sure Nyjah for is the
problem and he's attacking a hitch to
now I think I probably played it ok it
was it was unclear but yeah totally lost
any any sort of dragged there ok thanks
for watching